وبالحديث مشاهدينا عن الانسحاب فدعونا
نشرح الانسحاب الافتراضي الذي قد تنفذه
القوات الاوكرانيه من باخمت حيث ينظم
الاوكرانيون وفقا تقرير مناورات للفرمله
هذه المناورات يقوم بها الجيش الاوكراني
الان على خط الجبهه هناك طبعا الخروج
بخسائر وباقل خسائر ممكنه من هذه الجبهه
بجبهه بخموت تتمركز هنا القوات الاوكرانيه
حيث تقوم
بنشر خط دفاع اول يساند خط الدفاع الثاني
ويسان طبعا خط الدفاع الثالث وبالتالي
خطوط دفاع متتاليه لكي يتم خروج القوات
الاوكرانيه من بخموت عبر هذا الطريق دعوني
ان اشير اليه الطريق من هنا غربيه جبهه
باخموت الى
وطبعا تنسحب القوات الاوكرانيه من هذه
المنطقه التي تعتبر يعني خط الخروج الذي
يجنب القوات الاوكرانيه مزيد من الخسائر
في العتاد وفي العديد وهذه هذا الخط الذي
اشرت اليه هنا هو خط الامداد الرئيسي
للقوات الاوكرانيه بهذه المنطقه وهو طبعا
ما تحاول الان قوات فاجنر بالذات من
السيطره عليه عبر ضرب خط الامدادات هذا
بمزيد من الضربات ان كان المدفعيه وان كان
طبعا عمليات تفجير لكي يتم يعني قطع خطا
الامداد وبالتالي الحاق اكبر قدر من
الخسائر بالقوات الاوكرانيه في ضخمه